herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
droht den ukrainischen Truppen die einen
kesselung im Osten des Landes die Worte
des ukrainischen Präsidenten silency
sind meistens drastisch aber die von
gestern Nacht waren es besonders
angesichts der neuen russischen
Offensive im Osten der Ukraine
geboren
die derzeitige Offensive der Okkupanten
im Donbass kann die Region unbewohnbar
machen sie wollen popasna bachmut Lissy
Chance und Severus komplett zerstören
die wohl nowaka wie Mario Paul in
Städten und Orten näher an der
russischen Grenze in Donezk und luhansk
sammeln Sie alle diese kriegen können um
die Getöteten und Verwundeten in den
Kontingenten zur Okkupation zu ersetzen
all das und auch dass der portieren
unserer Einwohner und die Massentötungen
von Zivilisten ist eine offensichtliche
Politik des Genozids verfolgt von
Russland
soweit der ukrainische Präsident und in
der Tat die Lage im Osten scheint
wirklich sehr sehr ernst zu sein dort
oben die derzeit schwersten Kämpfe pro
russische Separatisten erklärten heute
die Einnahme der Stadt Liman im dornbas
die noch von den Ukrainern
kontrollierten Städte ließ sie Chans und
sevierodonets gedrohen von den Russen
eingekesselt zu werden besonders die
Großstadt sevierodonezk im Osten der
Ukraine seit Tagen schwer umkämpft es
ist eine der letzten großen Städte der
Region luhansk im donbas die noch von
der Ukraine gehalten werden nach
ukrainischen Angaben beschießt die
russische Armee bewusst Wohngebiete
allein heute sollen dabei mindestens
vier Menschen ums Leben gekommen sein
der Bürgermeister der Stadt spricht von
mehr als 1.500 Toten seit Kriegsbeginn
mittlerweile so heißt es sind mehr als
die Hälfte der Wohnhäuser zerstört von
den 130.000 Einwohnern sei nur noch ein
Zehntel in der Stadt verblieben noch
hiel die ukrainischen Kräfte den
Angriffen stand jedoch sollen
mittlerweile erste russische Soldaten im
Stadtgebiet sein so der Bürgermeister
wie erfolgreich ist die russische
Offensive im Osten der Ukraine droht den
ukrainischen Truppen die Einkesselung
darüber wollen wir gleich mit dem
ehemaligen Nato-General Egon Rams
ausführlich sprechen wenn Sie Fragen
haben einfach her damit wir werden sie
mit dem General gemeinsam versuchen zu
beantworten zunächst aber schalten wir
zu unseren zdf-reportern in der Ukraine
zum einen ist Henna Hebestreit in libro
die Millionenstadt henna ist nach Kiew
fracke von Odessa die viertgrößte Stadt
in der Ukraine und nur etwa 300
Kilometer von seviero Donezk entfernt
Hannah wie ist die Lage was weißt du was
hörst du über die Lage im Osten über
Lissy chansefierodoniez
also wenn wir uns mal auf die Lage im
Osten beschränken dann ist sie sehr
schlecht aus ukrainischer Sicht das sagt
Präsident selenski seit Tagen und das
was wir hören ist auch so dass der
Fortschritt der Russen dort anscheinend
sehr stark voran geht vielleicht nicht
so schnell wie man sich das in Moskau
gewünscht hätte aber der Fortschritt ist
offenbar ein stetiger wir haben das ja
auch aus aus London gehört von Präsident
von von Premierminister Boris Johnson
der gesagt hat die russischen Soldaten
fressen sich langsam aber sicher durch
den Don Bass hindurch hier in nepro
allerdings ist davon wenig zu spüren wir
sind 300 Kilometer von der Situation
entfernt hier ist eine Freitagabend
ausgangsstimmung ich würde sowas als
eine laue Sommernacht bezeichnen in
Mainz oder in Paris oder in Kiel oder wo
man auch sonst immer um diese Zeit Lust
wandelt sieht das nicht anders aus
jetzt sieht das alles friedlich aus du
hast es gerade gesagt hey na bei dir im
Hintergrund aber wenn du mit den Leuten
sprichst wie groß ist denn die Angst in
Newport wie gesagt auch 300 Kilometer
noch von den schweren Kämpfen entfernt
dass sich aber eben die Russen um den
Bild zu bleiben weiter vorfressen und
eben vielleicht in einigen Tagen in
einigen Wochen eben auch vor die Post
stehen
naja es ist schwierig auch so dass es
zwar alles sehr friedlich aussieht aber
auch sehr stark militärisch beschützt
ist also auf der Brücke hinter mir da
hinten da kann man auf beiden Enden muss
man an sehr starken militärkräften
Vorbeigehen wenn man da steht und dort
ein Foto macht dann dauert es nicht
wahnsinnig lange man findet sich in
irgendeiner kommentatore wieder wird auf
Herz und Nieren geprüft ob man denn nun
einen
ziviler Berichterstatter ist oder am
Ende irgendeiner ein ein Mensch mit
spionierenden Absichten es ist auch so
dass in der Stadt überall Sandsäcke
aufgehäuft und Panzersperren stehen
nicht mehr auf der Straße wie das wohl
zu Beginn des Krieges war sie stehen
daneben und können jederzeit wieder
aufgebaut werden und wenn man sich mit
den Leuten hier unterhält die sind ganz
klar davon überzeugt wenn der Donbass
fällt dann wird es früher oder später
auch einen einen Vorstoß in diese
Richtung geben also schon eine gewisse
Angst da was sagen denn die Leute oder
was erlebst du auch in Sachen
Waffenlieferungen kommen die denn
irgendwie näher erlebt man in die empor
das westliche Waffen Waffen aus dem
besten ankommen und nach Osten
weitergeschickt werden
naja das sind natürlich Sachen die jetzt
nicht in den Zeitungen und im Internet
veröffentlicht werden was die da gerade
über diese Brücken hier verschieben es
ist so dass uns der Bürgermeister von
Nico von ein paar Tagen gesagt hat das
vergangene Woche wohl mehrere Raketen in
Richtung dieser Brücke dieser
Eisenbahnbrücken geflogen sind die aber
die Brücke nicht erreicht haben heute
Nacht haben wir mitbekommen das war
heute morgen um 4 Uhr etwa gab es in
Luftalarm und auch während die Sirenen
geheult haben geflogen 10 km nördlich
von hier da drüben drei russische
Raketen in eine Stellung der oder in
eine Garnison der ukrainischen Truppen
da gab es sehr viele Tote und Verletzte
das haben wir auch als Schläge im Hotel
gehört das ist schon so dass man das
mitkriegt man weiß aber nicht galt jetzt
dieser Angriff den dort befindlichen
Soldaten oder war der vielleicht auch
irgendwas abgestellt was woanders
hingebracht werden sollte das wissen wir
von hier nicht das wie gesagt das
erfährt man hier nicht
ja vielen Dank für diese Information und
die Eindrücke Hannah Hebestreit in die
Pro im Zentrum des Landes jetzt gehen
wir in den Südwesten des Landes nach
Odessa und da ist unser ZDF Reporter
Johannes Hano Johannes die russischen
Truppen sind von der Krim aus nach
Westen vorgedrungen im Visier Odessa der
wichtigste Hafen der Ukraine der Zugang
zum Schwarzen Meer also sehr wichtig
sehr entscheidend wie ist denn die Lage
in Odessa
also ist eine sehr merkwürdige Situation
in nur der ist ja einerseits hannah hat
es ja auch aus seiner Region geschildert
die Leute gehen hier im Frühsommer nicht
abends in Restaurants in Straßencafés
und gleichzeitig hört man immer wieder
die Luftalarm Sirenen das nehmen die
Leute gar nicht so richtig war die Stadt
ist total befestigt an jeder Ecke gibt's
hier große Barrikaden Sandsäcke Beton
Barrikaden überall Checkpoints also die
Stadt bereitet sich hier vor das merkt
man auf ein möglicherweise russischen
Angriff auch auf Straßenkämpfer und
Häuser Kämpfe noch ist es nicht so weit
noch sind die russischen Truppen nicht
über nikolive gekommen das ist nämlich
eine Stadt vor und Esser die im Moment
noch schwer geschützt wird von
ukrainischen Truppen da gibt es heftige
artilleriegefechte die Stadt wird selbst
immer wieder auch von Russen mit
Clusterbomben also Streumunition
beschossen um die Leute dort zu
terrorisieren aber man braucht diese
Stadt um hier auf Odessa
vorzumarschieren gleichzeitig wir waren
heute in den Schützengräben an der Küste
hier in Odessa bereitet man sich auf
eine an Landgang der Russen vor also
dass sie hier versuchen zu anzulandten
um die Stadt von sehe einzunehmen das
geht aber wohl nur wenn man vorher von
Norden über nikolaiw einmarschiert ist
mit Truppen zur Unterstützung also
einerseits alles relativ friedlich
andererseits totale Anspannung und
dazwischen spielt sich hier alles ab das
ist ein sehr sehr merkwürdiges Gefühl
jetzt haben wir das eben auf der Karte
ja auch noch mal gesehen östlich der
Krim haben die Russen im Grunde das Band
geschaffen haben also die Ukraine
komplett vom Meer vom Asowschen Meer
abgeschnitten westlich der Krim ist
ihnen das eben noch nicht gelungen eben
weil Odessa nicht eingenommen ist noch
umkämpft wird aber Odessa wird ja von
der russischen Marine blockiert und was
bedeutet das genau
also das hat ganz verschiedene Dinge
bedeutet das einerseits kann hier nichts
eingeführt werden der Seeweg ist zu es
können keine Waffen nach Odessa
geliefert werden über den Seeweg und
andererseits kann hier auch und darüber
mit den vergangenen Tagen wieder
berichtet diese vielen Millionen Tonnen
Getreide die hier in den häfenlagern
oder noch in den auf den in den Silos
der Bauern hier rund um Odessa die
können nicht ausgeführt werden also das
ist tatsächlich strategisch ein Kampf
mit dem Hunger man geht ja davon aus
dass Putin in den Hunger tatsächlich
auch als Waffe einsetzt das ist das eine
zum anderen haben russische Truppen in
den vergangenen Tagen eine Brücke
bombardiert die Richtung Rumänien führt
das ist dir Versorgungslinie nach
Rumänien über die auch Waffen
transportiert wurden und Lebensmittel
transportiert worden aus der EU die ist
wohl zerstört genau dürfen wir das nicht
hier können wir das nicht sagen weil wir
da nicht hin dürfen wir haben es nur
gehört von den Bewohnern dort dass da
mehrere cruise-missile wohl
eingeschlagen sein sollen und da ist
diese Strecke die versorgungsstrecke
jetzt blockiert wir sind da heute mal
runtergefahren das ist ungefähr 50 km
Luftlinie weg von hier Odessa was wir
festgestellt haben ist dass die Straßen
absolut faul sind ewig lange Lastwagen
Schlangen die aus Moldawien sich in die
Ukraine hineinbewegen und wir haben auch
gesehen dass dort militärgeräte über
Moldawien nach Indien in die Ukraine
kommt auch hier nach Odessa und die
Militärsprecher mit denen wir vorhin
unterwegs waren haben uns gesagt im
Moment gibt es keinerlei
Versorgungsprobleme um die Stadt zu
halten
denn vielen Dank an beide an Dich
Johannes und eben auch ein Henna
hebelstreit einerseits Integra und
einmal in Odessa vielen Dank für die
Information und Schilderung vielen Dank
ja und bevor wir jetzt mit dem
ehemaligen Nato-General Egon Rams über
die militärische Lage vor allem im Osten
der Ukraine sprechen die drohende
Einkesselung der ukrainischen Truppen
eine Zusammenfassung der Lage am
heutigen 93 Tag des russischen Angriffs
auf die Ukraine
Zug aus limann diese Handyaufnahmen
sollen zeigen die ukrainische Soldaten
unter Feuer die umkämpfte Stadt im
Norden der Region Donezk verlassen die
Pro russischen Separatisten melden sie
hätten niemanden eingenommen eine
unabhängige Bestätigung gibt es noch
nicht die Stadt ist ein strategisch
wichtiger Verkehrsknotenpunkt ihre
Eroberung könnte einen russischen
Vormarsch auf slowensk und krematorsk
ermöglichen die unter ukrainischer
Kontrolle stehen Walter östlich liegt
zierverodonieck die Stadt gehört zu den
letzten Gebieten in der Region juchansk
die von der ukrainischen Armee
kontrolliert werden sie steht seit Tagen
unter Dauerbeschuss von den einst
130.000 Einwohnern sind die meisten
geflohen die die geblieben sind suchen
in dunklen feuchten Kellern Schutz
ich versuche nicht über die
Bombardierungen die Explosionen
nachzudenken ich will nein ich muss dass
ihr einfach Überleben
von drei Seiten greifen die russischen
Streitkräfte an um die Regionen Don
jetzt und johannskunter ihre Kontrolle
zu bringen die ukrainische Armee steht
enorm unter Druck den Ort propasna haben
pro russische Truppen bereits
eingenommen doch nach wochenlangen
kämpfen ist nicht mehr viel davon übrig
ja da ist er general Egon Rams ich grüße
Sie ganz herzlich vielen Dank dass Sie
mit dabei sind von drei Seiten greifen
die russischen Kräfte im Osten an wie
sehen Sie die Lage
guten Abend Herr Rüger
wir befinden uns in einer sehr
schwierigen Situation für die
ukrainischen Truppen zurzeit und der
wenn auch langsame Vormarsch der Russen
in den beiden Regionen dann jetzt und du
kannst geht offensichtlich weiter du
kannst es wenn ich das richtig sehe zu
mehr als 90 vielleicht 95% bereits in
den Händen der Russen von daher haben
sie da Vorteile erzielt oder Gewinne
erzielt mit denen vor vielleicht zehn
Tagen oder 14 Tage noch nicht zu rechnen
war
das Schlechte daran ist dass der vormaß
der rushen sehr beständig ist und
beständig weiter fortgeführt wird und
offensichtlich die ukrainische
Streitkräfte trotz ihrer hohen
Kampfmoral nicht in der Lage sind dieses
aufzuhalten
wenn wir auf den Westen schauen dann ist
sicherlich das eines der Ziele von der
russischen Seite Odessa einzunehmen und
dann nach Transnistrien und Moldau
aufzuschließen das hat dann zwei
Hintergründe es hat einmal die
Hintergrund dass man dann die gesamte
Küste der Ukraine in russischer Hand hat
dann braucht aber den Hafen Odessa mit
Blick auf seine trotz der Sperrung zur
Zeit Möglichkeiten für die Zukunft nicht
mehr geredet werden und es gibt einen
weiteren strategisch sehr wichtigen
Punkt dabei dann ist nämlich praktisch
die gesamte Ukraine von allen
meereszugängen abgeschnitten und wird
damit zu einem Binnenland und damit wird
auch der Nachschub insgesamt schwieriger
werden auch der über Schiene oder Straße
jetzt schauen wir uns vielleicht
gemeinsam noch mal im Osten eine Karte
genau an und die zeigt wie ernst die
Sache ist vielleicht so Einordnung erst
einmal der Blick auf die Karte wo wir
zum einen
severordon jetzt sehen und Lissy Chance
da oben ist Liman was angeblich
eingenommen worden sein soll durch Boris
pro russische Separatisten vor allen
Dingen sehen wir aber die wichtige
Verbindungsstraße von dissy Chance nach
bermud und wir sehen Po passna wo die
Russen einen Durchbruch geschafft haben
und das sind Bilder wir sehen hier
Einschläge links und rechts dieser
besagten Verbindungsstraße ein Auto das
Video ist vom Gouverneur von Johannes
gepostet worden Rast diese Straße von
Lissy Chance Richtung bachmut und es
zeigt wie links und rechts Granaten
russische Granaten einschlagen
eine Fahrt die lebensgefährlich ist aber
der Gouverneur von Johannes macht
deutlich
so viele Menschen versuchen zu fliehen
aus Lissy Chance und nehmen diese
lebensgefährliche Flucht mit dem Auto
über diese eine Straße in Kauf weil das
bleiben schreibt er in Lissy Chance noch
lebensgefährlicher ist das Video zeigt
eben ist von vor drei Tagen und zeigt
wie nah die Russen schon an diese
Verbindungsstraße ran gerückt waren am
Dienstag vermutlich so etwa fünf
Kilometer heißt es aus manchen Quellen
der General was würde das jetzt bedeuten
wenn diese Straße von den Russen
eingenommen wird also diese Verbindung
zwischen Lissy Chance uns hier
virodonetz und auf der anderen Seite
weiter im Landesinnern bachmut gekappt
wird also in die Hände der Russen fällt
also wenn diese Verbindung die Hände der
Russen fällt und damit im Prinzip
jeglicher versorgungsverkehr in diesen
Zipfel nach Osten rein unterbrochen
werden kann dann haben die Truppen die
dort sind wieder Betriebsstoff noch
Munition wahrscheinlich dann auch
irgendwann keine Lebensmittel mehr das
heißt es entsteht eine für diese
Soldaten in diesem Bereich befindlichen
Soldaten eine sehr schwierige Situation
die dann möglicherweise auch zu einer
Einkesselung führen kann aufgrund der
Stärke der Kräfte die man dort annimmt
wir reden über mehr als zwei Brigaden
wäre es von der taktischen Seite her
sinnvoll wenn die Ukraine sich aus
diesem Bereich zurückziehen würden um
diese Truppenteile nicht zu verlieren
und damit eine ähnliche Situation
reinzukommen wie wir sie in mariopol
erlebt haben das heißt die Einschließung
von ukrainischen Kräften könnte dann
entsprechende Verluste bedeuten und
diese Kräfte werden dann zu einem
späteren Zeitpunkt nicht mehr zur
Verfügung stehen
wir versuchen das alles mit einer
anderen Karte nochmal deutlicher zu
machen schauen mal hier John helen ist
ein Student an der Universität in
Helsinki und er hat sehr detaillierte
Informationen vor allen Dingen eben auch
Karten hier getwittert und wir schauen
uns das ganze einfach mal genauer an
diese Karte hier nämlich zum Beispiel
die das zeigt was sie gerade beschrieben
haben pro Pasca verpasner hier ist der
Durchbruch gelungen wir sehen hier Lissy
Chance Server dornets unter Druck durch
russische Truppen die also von Norden
von Osten von Südosten heranrücken man
sieht ja sozusagen die gedachte
Verteidigungslinie hier das Flussbett
und wenn nun die eine Meldung kommen
dass aus Lehmann aus dem Norden eben
russische Truppen weiter vorrücken und
eben aus dem Südosten dann ja sagt man
eben okay es droht diese Einkesselung
und es fängt damit an dass diese
Verbindungsstraße Weg ist was sagen Sie
jetzt aus mil generischer Sicht Rückzug
frontbegradigen ist das wichtigste was
ist wenn tatsächlich die ich weiß es
nicht vielleicht drei vier Brigaden wird
vermutet die oben in diesem dann
potenziellen Kessel sitzen tatsächlich
abgeschnitten werden was würde das ganze
für den Verlauf des Krieges bedeuten
also ich würde nicht sagen dass dieses
insgesamt für den Verlauf des Krieges
einen wichtigen oder entscheidenden
Einfluss hat aber ich kann nur das
wiederholen was ich gerade gesagt habe
die ukrainische Streitkräfte müssten
jetzt zu einem verzögerungsgeficht so
nennen wir das übergehen um aus diesem
aus diesem abgeschnittenen oder
abschneidungen bedrohten Bereich
herauszukommen denn ich bin davon
überzeugt dass diese Kräfte später noch
mal für die weitere Verteidigung der
Ukraine entsprechend benötigt werden das
heißt man geht aus diesem
Geländeabschnitt heraus versucht auf
diesem Wege Zeit zu gewinnen sie hatten
gerade schon den Begriff der Begradigung
der Front erwähnt auch das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt denn wenn die Front
kürzer wird braucht man zur Verteidigung
einer solchen Front weniger Kräfte und
kann dann andere Kräfte oder mit diesen
Kräften an anderer Stelle möglicherweise
das Gefecht gegen die vorrücken
russischen Truppen aufnehmen das wäre
ein wichtiger Punkt und aus militärisch
taktischer Sicht sicherlich auch die
richtige Entscheidung
dann haben wir ja ganz viele
Informationen die zusammenkommen
einerseits eben diese Meldungen limann
sei von prorussischen reparatisten
eingenommen worden wo passnah da ist der
Durchbruch den Russen gelungen also doch
anscheinend Fortschritte oder Erfolge
auf russischer Seite andererseits gibt
es immer wieder Quellen die sagen ja die
Ukraine die Russen setzen zum Beispiel
völlig veraltete 50 Jahre alte t-62
Panzer ein und was bedeutet das ist
mangelt an Material können Sie das Ganze
einordnen
also ich gehe da etwas anders ran als
sie das gerade gesagt haben ich gehe mal
davon aus dass auch in diesem Falle
wieder wie wir das schon bei den
Vorbereitungen für den Angriff erlebt
haben Truppenteile herbeigeführt worden
sind zusätzlicher beigeführt worden sind
die nicht aus dem Militärbezirk West
stammen der Militärbezirk West des
vergleichsweise mit modernen Gerät
ausgerüstet sondern ich vermute dass
hier möglicherweise Truppenteile
nachgeführt worden sind die in den
Bereich des Nordkaukasus spricht des
Militärbezirk Süd hereingehören und das
möglicherweise diese Truppen halt eben
noch mit T 62 also Panzer der ich sag
mal vor vor Generation ausgerüstet sind
aber ich würde auch diesen Panzer nicht
unbedingt abwerten er hat eine
schlechtere Panzerung als der T-72
beispielsweise das ist richtig von daher
ist ja anfälliger gegen
Panzerabwehrwaffen kurzer Reichweite
auch das ist keine Frage aber auch er
hat eine relativ starke Kanone und kann
damit auch auf Distanz gegen ukrainische
Kräfte eingesetzt werden von daher man
sollte das Waffensystem nicht
unterschätzen auch wenn es
möglicherweise leichter zu bekämpfen ist
und wie ich gerade gesagt habe ich gehe
davon aus dass diese Panzer zu Kräften
gehören die nachgeführt worden sind und
die nicht aus dem Militär Bezirk West
kommen
vielen Dank damit haben wir eine Frage
beantwortet die der User okidoki hier
gerade okidoki toki und so weiter
gefragt hat nämlich was bedeutet das
Russland veraltete Panzer einsetzt also
nicht unbedingt dass man sozusagen auf
dem letzten Loch pfeift und keinen
Material mehr hat sondern dass eben
einfach aus anderen Regionen Russlands
oder der Russischen Föderation Truppen
herangeführt werden es kommen mehrere
Sachen zusammen nochmal
selbstverständlich
darf ich noch einen Satz hinterher fügen
ich gehe zur Zeit davon aus dass
aufgrund der allgemeinen Situation
aufgrund der Verstärkung der NATO an der
nato-ostgrenze also auf NATO Territorium
Putin sehr sorgfältig darüber nachdenken
wird und der Generalstab sehr sorgfältig
darüber nachdenken wird ob sie die
besser ausgerüsteten Kräfte aus dem
Westen abziehen und offensichtlich tun
sie das im Augenblick nicht
jetzt blicken wir einfach mal auf die
Frage die sich auf viele Stellen wie
sieht es aus mit den Lieferungen mit
Waffen aus dem Westen jetzt kommen
mehrere Fragen zusammen und erstmal
diese Meldung bzw dieses Interview mit
dem ehemaligen Bundeswehr und
Nato-General Hans Lothar Domröse der
geht in einem mdr-interview davon aus
dass klar im Moment mit die große Welt
macht Russland wirklich mit Schwung
diese Offensive gestartet hat und
deshalb weil sie Reichweiten und
zahlenmäßig überlegen ist sagt Domröse
eben hier vor rückt und er sagt aber ab
Herbst könnten die Ukraine dann wieder
mehr Widerstand leisten in etwa einem
halben Jahr werde das Land viel mehr
westliche Waffensysteme haben bis dahin
werden sie noch schwere Schläge
hinnehmen aber die Zeit spiele etwas für
die Ukraine wenn sie denn durchhält kann
man das wirklich so sehen dass ich dann
im Herbst das Blatt wendet oder ist es
dann nicht möglicherweise viel zu spät
wenn die russischen Truppen tatsächlich
durchbrechen und weitere Erfolge feiern
ich würde diese Frage anders angehen ich
bin der Auffassung dass jeder
Quadratkilometer und jede größere Fläche
die in der Ukraine verloren geht also in
die Hände der russischen Streitkräfte
fällt oder wie jetzt in den beiden
Regionen du Hans condonjes in die Hände
der separisten Separatisten letztendlich
dazu führt dass dieses wieder wenn ich
die Rede von Herrn silenski beim
Weltwirtschaftsforum nehme irgendwann
wieder zurückerobert werden soll und
wenn ich Rückeroberungen machen will
brauche ich a eine deutlich stärkere
mobile Ausstattung hinsichtlich von
Panzer und Schützenpanzern das ist der
eine teil und der zweite Teil ist der
dass ich dann auch für eine solche
Rückeroberung entsprechende örtliche
überlegenheiten brauche und ob die
Ukraine in der Lage ist die herzustellen
auch mit westlichen Waffensystemen
herzustellen da habe ich zumindest noch
ein paar Fragezeichen also ich würde mir
eine solche Vorhersage im Herbst wird
alles besser derzeit noch nicht zutrauen
will der sehr vorsichtig mit umgehen ich
bin ein Optimist was die kampfmorale
ukrainischen Kräfte ich bin ein Optimist
dahingehend dass die ukrainischen Kräfte
auch mit modernen Waffensystemen
westlichen Waffensystemen werden umgehen
können aber ob das dann tatsächlich zur
Wende führt und zu welchem Zeitpunkt
da bin ich sehr vorsichtig und möchte da
keine konkreten Prognose machen
diese Frage auf die sie jetzt
geantwortet haben stellen sich eben auch
mehrere Caterpillar schreibt über
Youtube Herr general Rams welche
Auswirkungen hätte eine Teilung der
Ukraine für Europa er nimmt damit den
Gedanken schon vorweg wenn eben die
russischen Streitkräfte weitere Teile
erobern und nicht nur den don-bass also
die Region Johannes und Don jetzt unter
ihrer Kontrolle bringen sondern
weiterhin vielleicht die weitere Teile
vielleicht die Hälfte der Ukraine und
haben die Ukraine eine Möglichkeit sich
die besetzten Gebiete wieder
zurückzuholen sie haben gerade deutlich
gemacht das ist auch nicht gerade
einfach selbst wenn Waffen aus dem
Westen kommen
ja vielleicht darf ich dazu noch eine
Ergänzung geben wenn die Ziele die Putin
sich gestellt hat im Augenblick gestellt
hat das sind ja nicht die strategischen
Ziele die am 17 Dezember vorgestellt hat
bzw hinterher in seinem Brief an die
NATO noch mal benannt hat aber wenn es
ihm gelingt die beiden
Republiken Don jetzt und du kannst
Anführungszeichen russische Propaganda
zu befreien Anführungszeichen dann hat
er dort einen erheblichen Erfolg erzielt
den er auch wirksam in Russland
verkaufen kann und wenn es ihm dann noch
gelingen sollte tatsächlich die gesamte
Schwarzmeerküste in die Hand zu bekommen
dann ist die Ukraine in einem solchen
Falle mehr oder weniger ein Binnenland
und sie wäre dann wenn dann auf dieser
Basis einen Frieden geschlossen würde
viele reden ja von verhandlungsfrieden
dann wäre die Ukraine in meinen Augen
nicht mehr lebensfähig und das heißt
zwar dass im Kernland Kiew bis
in den Händen der Ukrainer verbleibt
aber alles andere was für die Wirtschaft
für die weitere Entwicklung des Landes
erforderlich ist damit das Land auch
seine Position auch als
getreidelieferant für die Welt behalten
kann würde dann möglicherweise verloren
gehen und das kann nicht in unserem
Interesse sein
damit haben Sie eigentlich auch schon
deutlich gemacht wie schwer es auch ist
zu definieren wann hat eigentlich eine
Seite gesiegt kann die Ukraine Siegen
fragt dr feelgut über der User hier über
Youtube general Egon Rams besteht für
die Ukraine eine reelle Chance diesen
Krieg zu gewinnen ich will halt damit
gleich vorwegnehmen wie will man das
definieren und wenn nein wohin führt der
Widerstand der ukrainischen Soldaten
danke für die Antwort vor Abschreiber
also das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage
damit auch eine sehr gute Frage die
dargestellt worden ist
es gibt so ein bisschen Prinzip Hoffnung
und ich habe großes Vertrauen in den
ukrainische Streitkräfte welches ich ja
im Prinzip wenn man den Angriff auf KF
sieht und den Angriff auf jakiv sieht
und dergleichen mehr bisher auch
entsprechend bestätigt hat aber wir sind
jetzt wie ich vorhin schon sagte in
einer kritischen Frage wo wir wo wir
sehr sorgfältig darauf achten müssen wie
viel Geländegewinne von der
separatistischen oder von der russischen
Seite erzielt werden und das sollte
möglichst niedrig gehalten werden wenn
man überhaupt eine Chance haben will das
Gelände wieder zurückzuerobern die
Bereiche wieder zurückzuerobern
Präsident selenski hat die Tage noch
gesagt dass er den Don Bass nicht
aufgeben wird der hat ja vom Genozid im
Don was gesprochen und von daher ist das
eigentlich sagt das mal weit gesteckte
strategisches Ziel welche sicherlich
auch zeitlich eine eine erhebliche Zeit
beanspruchen wird und die Situation ist
dann eine ausgesprochen schwierige
ich möchte ich würde mir wünschen da ich
der Auffassung bin dass die Freiheit
Europas des westlichen und
demokratischen Europas in der Ukraine
verteidigt wird dass dort zu wenig Raum
wie möglich aufgegeben wird das ist der
eine teil und lass die Ukraine hinterher
wieder in der Hand der frei gewählten
ukrainischen Regierung ist und nicht
irgendeiner Schattenregierung oder
irgendeiner anderen Organisation die
dann meint sie könnte große Teile
zumindestgroße Teil der Ukraine
entsprechend beherrschen
jetzt haben wir ganz konkrete Fragen s
Müller schreibt über Youtube stimmt es
dass die Ukraine 700.000 Soldaten
mobilisieren kann oder zumindest es
versucht und Sebastian Friedrich fragt
über Youtube wie sieht es mit Truppen
und waffenreserven bei den Russen aus
also bei den Russen ist die Frage
schwierig zu beantworten ich sagte
vorhin ich fange mit diesem Teil mal an
ich sagte vorhin dass der Militärbezirk
West der von Russland also es praktisch
der Bereich der an die NATO Grenzen
angrenzt bisher noch relativ wenig
Truppen abgegeben hat und wenn wir jetzt
beispielsweise über den Beitritt
Finnlands in die NATO reden da muss der
Teil oben im Norden gegenüber von
Finnland möglicherweise noch mal
verstärkt werden ich hatte das vorhin
als Erklärung benutzt um zu sagen warum
Truppenteile aus dem nordkorkasus
möglicherweise im weiteren Verlauf des
Krieges aus Sibirien nachgeführt werden
die eine schlechtere Ausrüstung haben
das ist der das ist der eine Teil dabei
der zweite Teil ist mit Blick auf die
ukrainische Seite
man muss sehr vorsichtig sein mit dem
was die Ukraine kann ich habe große
Hoffnung dass die Ukrainisch Kampfmoral
auch mit der Führung des Präsidenten
sich in gleicher Art und Weise weiter
fortsetzt ob sie 900.000 Reservisten
mobilisieren können kann ich nicht
einschätzen also mir ist bekannt dass
die ukrainische betrifft eine Stärke
gehabt haben zu Beginn des Krieges in
der Größenordnung von 200 bis 250.000
und dass sie in der Lage sind
Reservisten zu mobilisieren ist bekannt
aber die Zahlen die ich dort im Kopf
habe gehen dann noch mal etwa in die
Größenordnung 150 bis 200.000 das heißt
dann würden wir insgesamt über 400.000
reden was ich nicht im Griff habe sind
die vielen zivilen Bürger der Ukraine
die sich mit Beginn des Ukraine Krieges
haben bewaffnen lassen die mittlerweile
eine Ausbildung durchlaufen haben die
ich sag das mal im rückwärtigen Gebiet
der Ukraine wichtige Aufgaben zur
Sicherung und dergleichen ausführen das
sind mir keine Zahlen bekannt das heißt
ich kann die Zahl 900.000 nicht
bestätigen erste Aussage aber wenn die
Ukraine tatsächlich ich sag das mal eine
Größenordnung von etwa 400.000 Soldaten
aktivieren und in den Einsatz bringen
kann dann ist das schon eine beachtliche
Stärke mit der man auch das was die
Russen heute in der Ukraine haben das
heißt im Donbass und im Süden haben
durchaus ausbalancieren
so weit sozusagen zum Personal kommen
wir noch mal zum Material zu den Waffen
loose 210 schreibt über Youtube oder
fragt über Youtube wann kommen die
amerikanischen europäischen
Waffenlieferungen zur Geltung und wir
können uns auch noch mal einen ganz
aktuellen flammenden Appell des
ukrainischen Außenministers gemeinsam
anhören
we need heavy weapons wir brauchen
schwere Waffen die einzige Position wo
Russland uns voraus ist ist die Menge an
schweren Waffen ohne Artillerie ohne
mehrfach raketenwerfersysteme werden wie
ihre Truppen nicht zurückdrängen können
wenn ihnen die Ukraine wirklich am
Herzen liegt und sie wollen dass Sie
sich befreit dann senden sie mehrfach
raketenwerfersysteme so schnell wie
möglich
also ein weiterer Appell an den Westen
so schnell wie möglich Waffen zu liefern
wie sieht es aber mit diesen
Waffenlieferungen aus wir haben am
Montag klar gehört dass Gepard Panzer
Flakpanzer der aus Deutschland made in
Germany ja Mitte Juli geliefert werden
sollen 15 war die weiteren restlichen
dann ähm ja bis mitte ende August da
fragt man sich schon ist das nicht zu
spät wo doch jetzt wirklich wir haben es
gerade gesagt die schwersten Kämpfe im
Osten toben
also es ist so dass ich sage das mal
ganz vorsichtig die Frage die Nachfrage
nach schweren Waffen ja von der Ukraine
sehr vor sehr früh gestellt worden ist
nach Beginn des Krieges und das
vielleicht die eine andere Entscheidung
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland aber
vielleicht auch in anderen Ländern im
Vergleich dazu relativ spät gefallen ist
wir haben wie sie vorhin selber gesagt
haben oder berichtet haben den dreien 93
Kriegstag das heißt wir sind
mittlerweile weit über 12 13 Wochen die
wir hinter uns liegen haben und wenn wir
diese Waffenlieferungen zu einem
früheren Zeitpunkt ich sage mal in der
vierten fünften Kriegswoche aufgenommen
hätten werden Sie möglicherweise heute
schon da das gilt nicht nur für
Deutschland das gilt auch für andere
westliche Länder wir haben angefangen
mit leichten Waffen wie Panzerfäusten
und fliegerfäusten und dergleichen und
wir hätten schon damals von vornherein
zwischen fliegerfäusten und schweren
Waffen kein Unterschied machen müssen
oder dürfen und hätten diese Waffe
frühzeitiger in Marsch setzen können
das ist ein Versäumnis welches sich
möglicherweise negativ auswirkt auf die
Kriegsführung in der Ukraine und welches
zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt dann
möglicherweise auch noch mal zusätzliche
Menschenleben kosten wird das ist eine
sehr schwierige Situation und ich kann
nur ähnlich wieder Außenminister den
Appell dahingehend richten dass alles
was man an Waffen hat was man der
Ukraine zur Verfügung stellen kann und
will so schnell wie möglich in die
Ukraine gebracht wird und alle
Diskussionen über
es fehlt die Ausbildung man braucht so
und so lange um die Waffe bedienen zu
können und dergleichen mehr eingestellt
wird sondern diese Handlungen einfach
aufgenommen werden um hier endlich zu
erfolgen mit Blick auf die Versorgung
mit schweren Waffen und Waffen für die
Ukraine zu kommen
damit ist die Frage beantwortet was
Frank Mauersberger gerade schreibt was
kann der Westen kurzfristig tun um zu
helfen im Grunde genommen diese
Versprechen so schnell wie möglich
einlösen und Waffen zu liefern wie sie
ja sagen wir haben noch eine Meldung
gehabt
richtig also das ist die klare Antwort
des Generals der vielleicht auch noch
eine Sache uns einfach erklären kann
die putin will eine generalmobil-machung
wohl bisher vermeiden er hatte am 9 mai
dem Tag des Sieges über Hitler
Deutschland keine general mobil machen
angekündigt manch einer hatte das
erwartet er erhöht aber jetzt die
Altersbegrenzung für Soldaten und
verlängert auch Vertragszeiten für
Berufssoldaten was zeigt das
das Zeug das sehr offensichtlich ich
sage das mal vorsichtig an das Thema
general mobiler nicht ran will weil das
ein ganz klares Signal wäre an die
russische Bevölkerung dass ich Russland
nicht mehr in einer sonderoperation
sondern tatsächlich im Krieg befindet
das heißt das ist eine Vorsichtsmaßnahme
um den Zustand oder das narrativ welches
man bisher genutzt hat gegenüber der
russischen Bevölkerung zu erhalten
die Mittel die Vertragsverlängerung
durchzuführen oder die Altersgrenzen
aufzusetzen sind Mittel und
Möglichkeiten um Soldaten die im Dienst
sind
unabhängig sage ich mal von
Altersgrenzen und Vertragsdauer im
Dienst zu behalten und auf diese Weise
diese Soldaten weiter einsetzen zu
können das ist dann Nancy man sich dann
oder nennt man nicht mehr general mobil
machen sondern es ist halt eben ein
Unterlaufen an der General mobil machen
aber letztendlich mit dem Ziel mehr
Soldaten für die Streitkräfte zur
Verfügung zu haben
sie deuten es an dass man so ein
bisschen versuchen kann nur zu
spekulieren zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen
das Putin sich eben schaut offiziell
eine general mobil machen auszurufen
damit anzuerkennen es ist ein Krieg von
der von dem narratives ist eben eine
spezialoperation abzurücken es gibt die
konkrete Frage hier von Nexus Ranger
über Youtube wie hoch besteht die Chance
dass Putin intern gestürzt werden kann
würden sie aus ihrem Bauchgefühl sagen
es könnte auch für Putin gefährlich
werden wenn er dieses narrativ wechselt
und eine generalmobil machen anordnet
also damit zugeben muss es ist ein Krieg
und keine spezialoperation dass dann
eben auch intern rebelliert wird in der
Führungsspitze
also das kann ich nicht beurteilen ich
sage das in aller Deutlichkeit was die
Führungsspitze angeht gehe ich davon aus
dass er die Führungsspitze so ausgewählt
hat dass es alle ihm treu ergebende
Leute sind von daher befürchte ich von
daher keine Gefahr nur wenn sein
narrativ mit der sonderoperation oder
spezialoperationen in der Ukraine
gegenüber der russischen Bevölkerung
zusammenbricht dann ist die Information
in der russischen Bevölkerung draußen
und damit bekannt dass die
rolls-russland in der Ukraine einen
Krieg führt und das gibt möglicherweise
an etwas anderes Verhalten von Seiten
der russischen Bevölkerung auch dieses
ist in ihnen Auswirkungen schwierig zu
beurteilen und es wird sicherlich einige
Zeit in Anspruch nehmen bevor dieses
sich auch entsprechend in Russland
verbreitet bei den eingeschränkten
Informationsmöglichkeiten die
Bevölkerung russland hat
also die Stimmung sozusagen zu Hause die
Moral was gefühlt wird ist eben spielt
eben auch eine erhebliche Rolle in einem
Krieg darüber muss Putin eben auch
nachdenken was sagt die eigene
Bevölkerung zu Hause wenn wir einmal
noch mal auf die Karte kurz gehen könnte
die John Hilling hier der finnische
Student gezeigt hat gepostet hat wir
sehen noch mal ich möchte einmal noch
mal auf das ursprüngliche Thema nämlich
die einen kesselung zurückkommen wenn
hier in diesem Bereich um Lissy Chance
mehrere ukrainische Brigaden er schreibt
drei vier Brigaden wir können das jetzt
nicht nachprüfen aber in diesem Bereich
ja eben doch eine erhebliche Anteil
ukrainischer Soldaten ist und
möglicherweise durch diese
Zangenbewegung aus dem Südosten und aus
dem Nordosten eingekesselt würde was
würde das bedeuten vor allen Dingen wir
haben ja eine Einkesselung in Mario Paul
schon erlebt dass eben doch eine hohe
Anzahl an Soldaten in dem also Stahl
Stahlwerk
gesessen hat eingekesselt war sich am
Ende ergeben mussten da sind
Menschenleben gerettet worden aber die
Bilder haben ja auch eine gewisse
Bedeutung oder
das hat auch eine moralische Wirkung und
zwar eine moralische Wirkung sowohl auf
die ukrainische Bevölkerung als auch auf
die ukrainischen Soldaten ich gehe aber
davon aus dass die Ukraine von anderer
Seite her mit sehr guten nachrichtlichen
dienstlichen Informationen
satellitenaufklärung und dergleichen
verseucht wird so dass ich hoffe dass
der ukrainische Generalstab diese
Operation eines kontrollierten Rückzuges
ich hatte das vorhin Verzögerung genannt
tatsächlich auch in dieser Weise
durchführt um diese Soldaten dann mit
der Zahl die dann deutlich höher wäre
als das was sind also auf Stahl
den Russen in als Gefangene in die Hände
gefallen ist dass das verändert wird
auch dieses Thema auch dieses Thema mit
den
Gefangenen die nach meiner Auffassung ja
kriegsgefangenenstatus haben aus
mariopol ist immer auch noch ein Thema
welches ein anderes Risiko in sich wirkt
es gibt Politiker in der in Russland aus
der Duma die fordern diese Soldaten wie
Terroristen zu behandeln
wenn das der Fall ist dann kann ich nur
sagen dann ist das nicht das was ein
Kriegsgefangener ist der entsprechend
mit ich sag mal Schutzrechten
ausgestattet ist sondern dann reden wir
über Prozesse möglicherweise bis hin zur
Todesstrafe und das ist nicht das wo man
normalerweise mit Soldaten umgeht noch
mal gesagt ich hoffe dass der ukanische
Generalstab diese Operation dort so
führt dass dabei diese von dem Studenten
aus Helsinki genannte Zahl von drei bis
vier Brigaden nicht in die Hände der
Russen fällt ich bin aber auch mit
dieser hohen Zahl bin ich relativ
vorsichtig den Hinweis muss ich noch
geben weil ich mir nicht vorstellen kann
dass in diesem engen Raum so viele
Kräfte konzentriert werden
ich habe schon angedeutet dass es ist
jetzt eine Quelle die wir nicht
nachprüfen können wir können natürlich
auch nicht hundertprozentig überprüfen
wie viele Soldaten genau wo stehen das
ist verständlich dass wir das nicht
erfahren können und hier ein bisschen
spekulieren müssen aber kommen wir zum
Schluss ja
also mit der Spekulation sollte man
vorsichtig sein weil ja über solche
Zahlen oder solche Angaben dann
möglicherweise auch falsche ich sage das
mal Nachrichten bei uns in die eigene
Bevölkerung aber auch in die ukrainische
Bevölkerung gesendet werden und da
sollte man aufpassen dass man da nicht
falsche Signale schickt genau deshalb
unterstreichen wir das nochmal und zum
Abschluss aber ganz eben einfach eine
Einschätzung von ihnen einen Bauchgefühl
was hier auch mit der Frage
zusammenhängt die Patch Adams über
Youtube schreibt Zitat entscheiden ist
die Motivation der Kampfgeist und die
Ukrainer sind viel motivierter als die
Russen daher werden sie gewinnen sie
general Rams sind ja in den vergangenen
Wochen doch eigentlich immer recht
optimistisch gewesen haben gesagt ja es
ist diese
Kampfmoral der Ukrainer die dazu geführt
hat dass sie eben rum und rundum Kiew
eben den russischen Angriff
zurückgedrängt haben sie können einiges
erreichen jetzt erleben wir aber dass es
doch sehr viele russische Erfolge gibt
bei dieser Offensive im Osten und
vielleicht so ein bisschen an dem
heutigen Tag in den vergangenen Tagen
die russische Offensive da die Oberhand
eben gewinnt wie ist denn ihr
Bauchgefühl heute und Patch Adam
schreibt wie steht der General zu dieser
Einschätzung dass die Ukrainer es
schaffen werden heute sind sie am
heutigen Tag genauso optimistisch wie
noch vor wenigen Wochen
also ich bin nach wie vor optimistisch
aber es gibt viele Faktoren im
Augenblick die meinen Optimismus ein
bisschen dämpfen so formuliere ich das
mal das kommt jetzt auch vor allen
Dingen auf eine geschickte Führung der
Ukraine auf der taktischen operativen
Ebenen ich sprach das gerade schon aus
es darf keine Einkesselung geben weil
diese Kräfte zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
noch mal wieder gebraucht werden und
wenn das geschickt geführt und richtig
gemacht wird und die Kampfmoral die
Ukraine so hoch bleibt wie sie bisher
ist dann rechne ich der Ukraine
weiterhin die Chance zu dass sie diese
Auseinandersetzung mit Russland gewinnen
kann
aber wir würden sie die derzeitige Lager
einschätzen sind das schon entscheidende
Tage wer mit unseren
zdf-reportern ja gesprochen Import geht
man flanieren weiß aber auch wenn der
Durchbruch gelingt dann stehen die
Russen dann eben auch in der Mitte des
Landes auf einmal vor diepol sind das
wirklich kann man sagen entscheidende
Tage heute die im Osten oder an allen
Fronten in der Ukraine heute stattfinden
also ich würde sie nicht unbedingt als
entscheidend bezeichnen weil die Rechten
ja wir hatten über die Waffenlieferung
gekommen gesprochen wann immer sie
kommen mit einer weiteren Verstärkung
materiellen Verstärkungen der
ukrainischen Kräfte von daher wird es
vielleicht noch andere entscheidende
Tage geben und ich erlaube mit den
Hinweis dass wir bei der einsiegelung
oder Einkesselung von Kiew auch schon
über entscheidende Tage geredet haben wo
sich dann die Waage zugunsten der
Ukraine geneigt hat und ich hoffe dass
das beim weiteren Verlauf der Kämpfe in
der Ukraine die viele Tote auch viele
zivile tote Kosten weiterhin so verhält
dass die Waage sich zugunsten der
Ukrainer leicht
also dann trotz der Nachrichten die uns
erreichen trotz des Videos was wir
gesehen haben trotz dieser ganzen
Meldungen und des vorrückens der
russischen Truppen bleibt doch ein
bisschen Optimismus verbunden eben auch
mit rationalen handeln sie haben es ja
auch gesagt dass der Appell des
ukrainischen Außenministers durchaus
verständlich ist und Worten eben vom auf
westlicher Seite eben auch Taten folgen
können müssten so vielen Dank Herr
general vielen Dank für die Analyse dass
wir das alles gemeinsam ein bisschen
sortiert haben an den Fronten wie die
militärische Lage ist ganz herzlichen
Dank und ich sage bis bald einen schönen
Abend noch ja general Rams
ja und vielen Dank für das Interesse für
die regebeteiligung ich denke wir haben
viele Fragen beantwortet durch die
präzise Analyse von General Rams wir
haben aber auch viele Eindrücke bekommen
aus verschiedenen Teilen der Ukraine
nicht zuletzt eben durch unsere beiden
zDF-Reporter einer Hebestreit in Newport
und Johannes Hanau in Odessa ganz
herzlichen Dank für das Interesse
tschüss Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
tschüss und auf Wiedersehen